you know on this show sometimes we'll
look at the wacky and zany and kooky
things that right-wingers say and we'll
laugh and we'll say oh it's so silly and
it's so dumb but
we don't necessarily
always
worry for the future
of humanity
and the united states
and our legislative bodies on the basis
of you know every random thing that
marjorie taylor greene or whoever
necessarily says i have an example today
of something for you
that does make me really worried about
the future of american democracy quite
frankly um because of the level of
ignorance that it shows
combined with a sort of brazen
confidence despite that ignorance
and the reality
that this may be someone who is going to
be one of only 100 senators in the
united states
herschel walker is a trump-endorsed
republican senate candidate running in
the state of georgia and herschel walker
recently asked you know
if there's evolution if evolution is
real and we humans homo sapiens
evolved from apes
why
are there still apes on the planet if
the apes evolved to become humans
why are there still apes
we're going to look at the video in a
moment
there are more than 331
million people in the united states
only 100 at a time get to be members of
one of the most powerful legislative
bodies in the country the united states
senate one of those 100 might be someone
who questions
the truth
of evolution because there are still
monkeys
on planet earth
let's take a look at the clip this is
this is genuinely depressing it really
brings me it's i i have fear and despair
because of this i have no
pleasure this is not fun
here that means somebody up there had to
say let there be light that the earth
started and then he had to put someone
there on earth remember adam was there
remember adam came there then eve came
so somebody had to start it out
so that means it had to be a god because
he didn't just some bomb blew up and
started out and then i tell you
something now that we're gonna get to
the really crazy part
this idea that listen if there was some
first human here's the first human
because you start this that
this is not new stuff we're treading on
very worn ground here the idea that you
sometimes hear from creationists is well
okay listen
i came from a human mother
and my mother came from a human mother
and my grandmother came from a human
mother and so if you just follow that at
some point there was the first human
mother
and therefore that person must have been
created like that by a god or higher
power and of course when you understand
the slow process of evolution
and you understand how that works
you realize that the premise is wrong
it's logical to think
if ad infinitum
it was my mom and her mom and her mom
and her mom and her and it was just all
modern humans right you might end up
saying well i mean somebody must have
designed and created that first human
but we understand that that's not the
case so this alone we could spend an
hour on but let's get to the really
wacky part that's getting a lot of
attention as i heard i think about this
because
at one time science said man came from
apes it's not at one time but by the way
but yeah okay
did it not
every time i read or hear that i think
to myself you just didn't read the same
bible i did well this was interesting
though
if that is true
why are there still apes
think about it you know now you're
getting too smart for us no no no no
think about this we have an evolution
that is we've gotten so intelligent that
if that is true why are there still apes
and then the conception of a baby
let me tell you the science can't do
that they still trying to do it but it
can't because there had to be a god
so when god came
okay
now
this is not actually a crazy question i
mean you go you know you go to third or
fourth grade
when
i think that's when kids start being
taught about evolution
there are lots of curious
uh naive wide-eyed bushy-tailed eight
and nine-year-olds who would say hey but
if we came from apes why are there still
apes didn't the apes become human and of
course there's an answer
humans did not evolve from a modern
living ape like a modern chimpanzee
we evolved and descended from a common
ancestor of apes we share
a common ancestor that's the best
science we have right now which lived
and died
in the distant past and that means we're
related to other apes
and we and those other apes came from an
earlier
ape of some kind
now
that's an eight or nine-year-old that
would ask that
imagine if herschel walker becomes a
senator i mean really think think you
know we have 331 million people in this
country to pick from some of them are
kids so we're not literally okay but
we've got hundreds of millions of people
to choose from
how do we solve really serious problems
in this country inequality
poverty education
hunger
uh climate change
when we have a hun it's just a hundred
people in the senate and at least one of
them may there might be others in the
senate who believe the same stuff but
when one of your hundred is a senator
saying if evolution is real why are
there still apes on planet earth
how do we solve problems if that's the
case we can't
and so when we wonder man why
politics is so log jammed and we just
we're not getting anywhere and it's
these
trivial arguments about stupid stuff and
people getting fined for not wearing
masks and people who think the vaccines
modify your d how
we have 331 million people
the senate has 100 members representing
those people and a guy who's saying if
we if evolution is real why are there
still monkeys on earth has a genuine
shot at becoming one of those hundred
and is endorsed by former president
donald trump
it doesn't bode well
it doesn't bode well and it is not funny
it stopped being funny a while ago
one of our sponsors is little spoon your
one stop shop for easy healthy meals and
snacks for your baby toddler or big kid
if you're a parent of any age child
little spoon makes healthy meal times
simpler and it saves you hours at a very
reasonable price
little spoon makes everything fresh just
like homemade but it's delivered to your
door and ready in seconds pop it in the
fridge or freezer and it is ready when
you are they have 100 organic cold
pressed baby food for every eating stage
awesome food for toddlers and for kids
they even just launched a new line of
on-the-go smoothies that kids love
everything is nutritionally balanced no
junk food but it is kid approved it's
food that they'll actually eat and enjoy
and you can't beat the prices with kids
meals under five dollars baby food and
smoothie snacks under three dollars
little spoon is giving my audience 50
off your first order go to
littlespoon.com and use the code pacman
the link is down below